All right, Alessia and Josh,
your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
[randomized beeping]
"Before He Cheats,"
by Carrie Underwood.
Who knows that one better?
- Uh, maybe me? Do you know it?
I know it.
- I don't know it very well.
- I think I know it.
- Okay.
- All right, so Alessia's
gonna go for it.
It's all on you, Alessia, okay?
- Oh, man.
- Make sure you just get
really close to that mic.
- Oh, God, yeah, sure.
Okay.
- That's where the wat--
that's where
the hose is connected.
All right.
Whenever you're ready,
go for it. Good luck.
- I'm so nervous.
- The words will come on first.
- Okay.
[Carrie Underwood's
"Before He Cheats" playing]
- You nervous?
- Uh-oh.
- I think we're gonna get wet.
- ♪ Maybe next time he'll think
before he cheats ♪
- Oh!
- I'm sorry! I'm sorry!
I didn't know
she knew all the lyrics.
- You said it was a squirt!
- I know,
I did say it was a squirt.
It's a lot of squirts at once.
- Oh, no.
- Can we see that again
in slow motion?
[slow-motion] I'm sorry!
Okay, Joseph and Chance,
it's your turn.
Let's see what song
you guys got.
[randomized beeping]
"This is How We Do It,"
by Montel Jordan.
- Okay.
- I'm so scared!
- Who's gonna sing this one?
- I'll do this one.
- All right. Ooh, confident!
- Fo sho.
- He's from LA.
- I'll get them back, for sure.
- Whenever you're ready.
- This is how--
[music starts]
♪ Monty, yo, we made it
- Yeah!
- Yo! [laughs]
- Squirt them now!
Squirt them now, Jimmy!
- I love that--I love that
as he's delivering the line,
he's looking over
at you guys, like
♪ "Monty, I made it"
He's like, "I want to
see you guys get drenched."
That was awesome.
- Whoo!
- Can we see that again
in slow motion
just 'cause it's worth it?
Why not?
- Oh, great.
- Whoa!
- Oh, it shot higher than me,
'cause I'm short.
- All right,
for this final song
all four of you are going to
take turns singing
so pay attention
to your screen.
You'll switch off line by line.
When the music stops,
you have to nail the lyrics,
or you and your partner
will get sprayed.
And this round
is worth 200,000 points,
so whoever wins this
wins the whole thing!
[cheers and applause]
Let's see what
our final song is.
[randomized beeping]
"Livin' on a Prayer,"
by Bon Jovi.
- Oh, great, okay.
- Why are you smiling, Chance?
- I don't know this song!
- Okay, all right.
- There's a chance!
We can do this! We can do this!
- Alessia--well, you gotta hope
that it just doesn't
end on you, that's all.
Alessia, you're gonna
start us off, okay?
- Okay.
- Watch out, here we go, bud.
Whenever you're ready.
- [hums] Okay.
[music starts]
- Joseph, you're next.
- Josh.
- Chance!
- Alessia!
- Joseph!
- ♪ Take my hand
♪ And we'll make it, I swear
♪ Whoa
- Oh, he got it!
- ♪ Livin' on a--
Oh, what?
- That was right!
That was right!
- What happened?
Oh! Oh!
- No way, I was right!
Yo, I had that CD
when I was 12!
Those are the words!
- That's not fair!
- "We'll make it, I swear!"
- Boo!
- Oh, no, that was a mistake.
- [sinister laughter]
- Doom Box made
a big mistake right there.
- Wait, so it was wrong?
What happened?
- I was celebrating--
- [laughs]
- Mid-celebration when
I got squirted in the face.
- And he's gotta get the line?
He got the line!
He got it right!
- Got it right!
- Sorry, you guys! I'm sorry!
I'm sorry it happened to you.
But can we get a--
I just want to get slo-mo
of Chance thinking he won
and then getting
zapped in the face.
Let me get a look at that.
- [slow-motion]
♪ Livin' on a
- [slow-motion] Oh, what?
- That was--wait!
That was right!
- What happened?
- Congratulations!
Get out of there.
I apologize for the judges.
Bad call but great job.
Really great.